Okay, so we have officially left the bond
market, the money market, where we
obviously identified a number of leading
indicators. We are now going to move on to
more leading indicators. We're going to
move on to surveys. So welcome to video
number seven, where we're going to look at
now the ISM Manufacturing Report on
Business Survey, leading to surveys.
Leading indicator number three. So let's
get into this. What have we learned so
far? The leading indicators that we've
covered so far, real interest rates, the
yield curve, corporate credit spreads, and
M2 money supply growth as an accessory to
those leading indicators. And also, if
you've done the IPLT video series, we also
added the fix here as well.
So, so far in the PTM video series, what
we've looked at are indicators in the
money markets and the professional side of
the industry. So the professional market,
so the collective of individuals and
institutions that make up the professional
side. We use these leading indicators to
make decisions in how to allocate capital
across asset classes. Also, the Federal
Reserve is
very important. The Fed also monitors
these indicators every day and uses them
as instruments to make decisions in how
they would like capital to be distributed
across asset classes and throughout the
economy. For want of a better word, you
know, we've been using this word a lot.
They manipulate the leading indicators as,
and use them as leading indicators.
So let's say, let's say, let's say, let's
say, let's say, let's say this.
two parties, two entities in the private
sector, businesses and consumers. And the
decisions that
they make are affected by a number of
things. Businesses, for example, when it
comes to the
relative price of money, what are we
talking about here? Well, we're talking
about the corporate
bond market, short term and long term
borrowing, and the cost of that borrowing
and the cost
relative long term versus short term.
Businesses obviously make decisions at a
corporate level
based on the relative price of money.
Additionally, consumers, they are making
decisions based on
long term cost of money, and short term
cost of money, and relative to each other.
So the
absolute level and the relative level. So
for example, short term loans at the bank,
car
loans, mortgages, long term loans, etc,
etc. What they're also doing, businesses
in particular,
is they are making decisions based on the
risk across asset classes. Why? Because
they're
running a business, they're running a
corporation, and they have a balance
sheet. So the decisions
on how businesses fund their business
operations are affected by the relative
risk across asset
marketplaces, and the relative risk across
asset classes, and the relative risk
across asset classes, and the cost of
debt. So the price or level of interest is
the price or level of interest. So the
price or level of interest is the price or
cost or level of interest. So the price or
level of interest is the price or cost or
level of interest. So the price or level
of interest is the price or cost or level
of interest. So the price or level of
interest is the price or cost or level of
interest to service debt in order to raise
money relative to raising money.
raise money relative to raising money via
the equity market and the relative cost
between the two.
Now, we are going to be concentrating on
businesses for the next few videos.
And if you recall from video five, we
previously covered how businesses are
directly affected by
the price or cost of money when we
discussed corporate credit spreads and
aggregate corporate
bond index spreads. So here, rather than
repeat what we've already looked at
earlier,
to remind yourself, just go back and read
over the following slides that are on the
screen here
from video five, just to refresh your
memory. And if you recall from those
slides,
we learned that corporate bond indices, so
the spread at which corporate bonds trade
over
the 10-year treasury, the risk-free rate,
the spread is a predictor of expansionary
and contractionary
economic conditions, and also an indicator
of economic risk. Now, let's think about
this dynamic, because
companies don't report every day, of
course. They report publicly every
quarter, similar to GDP,
and earnings reports are backwards
looking. So, the Q1 earnings report, for
example,
is not reported in Q1, it's reported after
Q1. Businesses report quarterly and
earnings reports are,
by definition, a lagging indicator.
Businesses themselves, however, in between
their quarterly earnings
reports, they witness the real economy
every day in their daily sales and
earnings.
They also, inside their own businesses,
witness in real-time metrics that they
measure and use to measure
their business performance that are
additional to sales and earnings.
And as traders and portfolio managers, we
can get some really useful information on
this stuff,
publicly available in the market. We get
feedback from companies on these measures,
via surveys. And these surveys themselves,
serve as an additional leading indicator
to GDP expansion and
contraction, and therefore, stock market
direction and potential stock market
returns.
Now, unlike the leading indicators that
we've looked at so far in the PTM video
series, so,
interest rates, real interest rates, the
yield curve, corporate credit spreads, and
M2 money supply
growth, business surveys themselves can't
be directly manipulated by the Fed. And
also, very obviously,
a survey is not a tradable instrument, but
they do provide us with a really good
insight into the economy.
And we can use them as leading indicators
to make trading decisions. So, to predict
the future
and use tradable instruments like equities
to express our views of the future.
And surveys in conjunction with the money
market indicators that we've been looking
at so far are a
really vital component of a trader's
overall systematic process, because we're
trying to figure out which way
the macro wind is blowing, and therefore,
which way money is flowing in the
financial markets,
and which way it's likely to flow in the
future. And also, don't forget, the Fed is
watching too.
The Fed will be looking at these surveys
too. So, these surveys can be used by
traders and PMs
as a leading indicator or predictor of
Federal Reserve activity.
Now, as I mentioned previously, we're
going to be concentrating on looking at
businesses in the next
few videos, but we are going to look at a
number of surveys that act as leading
indicators to future
economic growth, stock market direction,
and potential returns in the stock market.
The first one we're
going to look at is the Institute of
Supply Management, the ISM Manufacturing
Report on Business.
And they release every month a
Manufacturing Report on Business, the
Purchasing Managers Index,
on the first business day of each month.
The link is on the screen. You can go to
this link,
and you can download the ISM release every
month. So, we are looking here in this
video at the manufacturing
sector in the United States. The next
video, we will be looking at the ISM Non
Manufacturing Report on
Business, which is for services companies.
And that is also released each month.
We're going to be looking
at that in the next video. As a reminder,
there's only two private sector entities
that make up an economy,
businesses and consumers. The government
is the public sector. But when we look at
businesses themselves,
we split this up into manufacturing and
non-manufacturing sectors. And there's two
main reports
in the United States, two main surveys
that as traders in PMs, we look at because
they're very, very important.
And they are the ISM Manufacturing Report
on Business and the ISM Non Manufacturing
or Services
Report on Business. Now, how does this
split up in the US economy? Well,
the manufacturing sector makes up 20% of
the US economy. And the services sector
makes up 80% of the US
economy. But that is not a percentage
that's equal to their importance. They are
both equally as important
as each other. And many would argue for a
few reasons, which we'll get into in a
moment, that the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business is more
important than the services report on
business.
Let's have a look at how the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business is
compiled. So, every month,
the Institute of Supply Management sends
out a questionnaire to members of the ISM
Business
Survey Committee. And this questionnaire
asks them to identify month-over-month
changes, if there's any,
for each sub-index in the table at the top
of the page. So, who are these members?
Well,
they are the top 300 largest US
manufacturing companies in the United
States. And the survey
asks those 300 manufacturing companies
questions relating to their business
activity in the previous
month that covers five areas with an equal
weighting. So, we can see them at the top
of the screen,
new orders, production, employment,
deliveries, and inventories. And each of
those five areas
has an equal 20 percent weighting. Now,
the ISM Manufacturing Report on Business,
sometimes called the PMI,
the Purchasing Managers Index, is
significant because it reflects physical
goods, physical,
real goods that are bought and sold in the
US economy.
Also, the data for the Manufacturing
Report goes back as far as 1947. Whereas,
services data only goes back to 2008. So,
there's more historical data and
therefore,
higher statistical significance. And these
are the two main reasons why a lot of
traders and PMs,
still to this day in the market, believe
that the Manufacturing Report on Business
is a more important
indicator than the Services Report on
Business. So, with the Manufacturing
Report on Business, we have
more data and it's about physical, real
goods bought and sold in the US economy,
not contracts or consulting
or services or anything like that. It's
real goods, physical goods, widgets in
factories, etc. So,
higher statistical significance and
physical, real goods. But what about the
survey design of the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business? How is
it actually put together? It's useful to
understand this
as fundamental knowledge as to how the
survey actually works. So, the PMI, the
Purchasing
Managers Index, is a composite index based
on seasonally adjusted diffusion indexes
for those five
indicators that were in the table. And a
diffusion index simply measures the degree
to which a change in
something is dispersed, spread out or
diffused in a particular group. So, if in
a given sample population,
all members of a particular group of
people are asked if something has changed
and in which direction,
they can only answer in one of three ways.
They can only say it's increased, it's
decreased,
or there's been no change. And what a
diffusion index does, what it indicates,
is the degree to which the
change is dispersed or diffused throughout
the sample population. Now, respondents to
ISM surveys indicate
each month, so in the monthly surveys,
whether particular activities in their
business, so for example,
like new orders have increased, decreased,
or remained unchanged from the previous
month.
And how the ISM calculates the ISM
indexes, they do this by taking the
percentage of respondents
that report that the activity has
increased, so conditions getting better,
and adding it to one
half of the percentage that report that
the activity has not changed or stayed the
same. And then they add
those two percentages together. So, using
half of the same percentage effectively
measures the bias toward a
positive, so an index above 50%, or a
negative index below 50%.
Now, we can run through a quick example
here of how this actually works. So, an
example of calculating
a diffusion index. So, if the response is
20% better, 70% the same, and 10% worse,
how does the diffusion index calculate?
Well, the diffusion index would be 55%.
So, that worked out is
20% plus 50% of 70%, and we get to 55%. A
reading of 50 on the index, so a reading
of 50%
indicates that there's no change at all
from the previous month. So, above 50 is
indicating positive,
and below 50, negative. As you can see,
when we work out the example here for the
diffusion index
calculation, 20% are reporting better, 10%
are reporting worse, and 70% the same. So,
when we add up and do our
calculation of 20% plus half of the 70%,
we get a positive number. We get an index
above 50, and we get 55%.
Now, as mentioned previously, you saw the
table earlier, there's five main areas
that are included
in the diffusion index. So, in the
diffusion index of the ISM Manufacturing
Report on Business,
these five areas are New Orders,
Production, Employment, Deliveries, and
Inventories. There are also
other parts to the survey, the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business, that are
not included in the Diffusion
Index. They are Customer Inventories,
Prices, Order Backlog, Exports, and
Imports.
So, what we are primarily interested in,
as Traders PMs, is Measurable Data. So, we
are interested really in
the Diffusion Index itself, and we're
interested in the Components. So, we are
interested in New Orders,
Production, Employment, Deliveries, and
Inventories. In your own time, and for
further learning,
you can obviously look at the rest of
them. So, Customer Inventories, Prices,
Order Backlog,
and Exports, and Imports. But for the
purposes of the PTM Video Series, we're
only going to be looking at
the components of the Diffusion Index and
the Index itself. So, let's have a look at
these components.
Let's see what they actually represent as
part of the overall index. So, let's have
a look at the
components. Firstly, New Orders. What is
that? Well, New Orders reflects the level
of New Orders
from customers of the manufacturing
business. So, if you think about what this
represents, the survey,
the questionnaire is asking these
manufacturing businesses, has there been a
change, positive,
negative, or no change, this month
relative to the last month in New Orders?
That's obviously going to
be a very useful piece of data for any
traders and PMs in the financial markets
between quarterly earnings
reports, because we're being told by
manufacturing businesses what's happening
in real time to their
businesses, to new orders. Next up,
Production. This measures the rate and
direction of change,
if any, in the level of production at the
manufacturing businesses. So, again,
positive, negative, no change.
Month on month. This is important data.
Next up, Employment. This reports the rate
of increase
or decrease in the level of employment at
the manufacturing businesses. Are they
hiring more people?
Is the rate increasing? Are they hiring
less people? Is the rate decreasing? Or is
there no change?
So, again, a very important piece of data.
Next up, Supplier Deliveries. This tells
us if deliveries
from the manufacturing businesses'
suppliers are faster or slower. So, this
gives us a good insight
into the speed and efficiency of the
supply chain. Next up, Inventories. This
tells us the increases month
on month or decreases month on month in
inventory levels at manufacturing
businesses. So, the question is,
is, is our manufacturing companies
increasing inventories or decreasing
inventories. So, all of these numbers
are the important numbers that make up the
ISM Manufacturing Report-Up Business
Diffusion Index,
or sometimes called the Composite or
Aggregate Index. And these are the numbers
that are important
to traders and PMs to us in attempting to
predict future GDP growth in the US
economy,
markets, stock market direction, stock
market direction and potential returns in
the stock market and also Fed policy.
Now, we mentioned that there was other
information in the Manufacturing Report on
Business,
information on areas of manufacturing
companies from the respondents that is not
included in the Diffusion Index,
customer inventories, prices, backlog of
orders, new export orders and imports. In
your own time, you can
self-educate and look into these areas
yourself. There is obviously some useful
information to glean from this,
but it's not our primary focus. Our
primary focus is the data that's included
in the Aggregate or Composite
Diffusion Index. In the Downloads area to
this video, you'll see a couple of
spreadsheet files there.
We're going to be looking at some data now
and some charts of the ISM Manufacturing
Index and its components,
and also the ISM Manufacturing Index
relative to S&P 500, Direction, Returns
and GDP. And you can
download all of that data in the
spreadsheet, in the Downloads area, and
have a look at those
spreadsheets yourself and see how they
work in your own time. Also, when ISM data
is
released every month, it's a very useful
exercise to update those spreadsheets
yourself every month.
Now, in the spreadsheets, you're going to
see visual representations of the data as
well as the data
itself. So, what are we looking at here? A
visual representation of the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business Index,
the Purchasing Managers Index, the
Purchasing Managers Index, and we're
looking at an all-time data series.
So, if you look on the screen, if you look
at the X axis, you'll see that the data
goes back to 1947 up to
present day. And you'll see on the Y axis,
we have a range for the Aggregate
Composite Diffusion Index of 20 to 80.
Now, what else do you notice? Well, you
should also notice the red line going from
left to right,
which is essentially a linear line of best
fit. And that line of best fit is above
the 50 level. So,
above 50, which is no change, above 50,
which is positive change, and below 50 is
negative change.
So, with this being above 50 across this
whole data set, what does that tell you?
It tells you that
there's more positives than negatives. And
this is consistent with business cycle
history
of expansions and contractions. Expansions
last longer than contractions.
So, throughout history, in the
manufacturing sector, we get long periods
of expansion.
So, economic growth, growth in the
manufacturing sector, with occasional
quick and sharp moves lower,
where we get contraction in the
manufacturing sector throughout the data
history.
And what we are looking at here is the
economic business cycle in itself.
So, if we zoom in here and we look at the
period from 1990 to present day,
let's have a look at what the ISM
Manufacturing Index was doing at certain
moments in time.
Well, we can see the last time it was
below 50 significantly. That was in 2020,
during the COVID collapse,
the COVID economic lockdown, and the
recession that occurred during that time.
Remember,
a recession is not just an economic
contraction. A recession is two quarters
of negative GDP growth.
You'll see previous to that, in 2015,
2016, you'll see that the ISM was below 50
there as well,
but we didn't have a recession. We just
had some economic contraction. And then,
if we look,
keep looking back further, we get to the
global financial crisis in 2008, 2009,
where the ISM went below 50
for the first time way before the economic
collapse in the global financial crisis.
So, you can see that it took a huge
nosedive in the global financial crisis of
2008, 2009.
And look at the periods in between these
big moves down in the ISM Manufacturing
Index.
You can see that for pretty much a decade,
other than a few prints below 50, over an
entire decade,
the ISM was pretty much the whole time
above the 50 level, indicating that the
manufacturing sector is expanding.
So, you can definitely see here, when we
zoom in to the last 30 years, that for the
most part,
the ISM Manufacturing Index has positive
data points, meaning that the
manufacturing sector in the US economy is
reporting growth on a month-on-month
basis.
What you also notice is that there's very
obvious peaks and troughs in the ISM
Manufacturing Index.
If we look below 50, other than the global
financial crisis in 2008 to 2009,
you can see that the low points seem to be
around the 40 to 45 level.
Somewhere in that region, that's where
historically the ISM troughs, excluding
the global financial crisis,
where you can see on the chart, that was a
big outlier, where the ISM troughed
between 32.5 and 35.
Now, if we look at the area above the 50
level, where we are indicating expansion,
we can see a very clear trend where the
ISM tends to peak.
So, where the ISM Manufacturing Index
tends to peak historically.
This tends to occur around the 60 level.
So, let's take note of that.
There are areas in the ISM Manufacturing
Index, historically, that we call peaks
and troughs,
and we have to pay attention to these
levels because they're very important.
As traders and portfolio managers, we can
glean a lot of information out of the
level of the Composite
Manufacturing Index, the Aggregate Index.
Let's have a look at this, and you'll see
this in the Downloads area as well.
This is the total data going back to 1947.
The total data of the ISM Manufacturing
Index relative to quarter-on-quarter
annualized GDP growth.
And what you'll see here is that the ISM
tends to move at the same time or before
as GDP growth is reported.
So, remember, when GDP growth is reported,
it's backwards-looking.
The ISM, for the most part, is a predictor
of what GDP growth will be on a quarterly
basis.
So, visually, we can see this, that when
the ISM is above 50, we should be
expecting,
based on historical trends, that
quarter-on-quarter annualized GDP growth
will also be positive.
And when the ISM is below 50, we should
expect quarter-on-quarter annualized real
GDP growth
to be contracting, so to be negative. And
we can see this visually on the chart.
Now, of course, this chart, because of all
data,
it's a little bit messy to look at
visually. We can zoom in and we can have a
look at the last few
business cycles. So, we can see on the
chart, when we look at the ISM
Manufacturing Index in white,
and GDP growth quarterly, annualized real
GDP growth in blue. We can see a
relationship here. It's very obvious.
We can see, for example, if we look on the
right-hand side at 2019-2020, we can see
that the ISM
went below 50 in 2019. However, GDP growth
was reported as slightly positive during
that period.
But we can see in 2020 that the ISM
obviously took a nosedive due to COVID and
the economic lockdowns,
and so did real GDP growth. This situation
here, obviously, we covered this earlier
in the video
series where when we saw the Fed take
action in 2019. And that's probably why
GDP growth didn't actually
collapse in 2019. It took COVID and the
economic lockdown to make GDP growth
collapse.
But there's no doubt about it that in
2019, there was a reported slowdown from
the US manufacturing sector
in 2019. And the Fed decided to take
action for this and other reasons. Now, if
we look a little bit
further back, if we look at the financial
crisis of 2008-2009, you can see very
clearly on the chart,
when we look at the data being reported,
that the ISM went below 50 in 2007. And it
stayed below 50 for
quite a while. And what happened? Yes, GDP
growth went negative. And we had a
recession. And when you look
at all of the data for the ISM
Manufacturing Index relative to GDP
growth, roughly speaking, it predicts
GDP growth around 80% of the time
throughout history. And the other 20% of
the time, we get some false
readings. But it's very reliable. The data
goes back to 1947. And 80% of the time, we
get GDP growth
going in the same direction as the ISM
predicting with a lag, with a time lag.
And that time lag is
anything between 6 and 18 months. So when
we think of our predictor list, our
dynamic predictor list of
forecasting economic growth, the ISM
Manufacturing Index is very, very useful.
In the download as well,
you're going to see an analysis where we
look at the ISM Manufacturing Index,
it's relative to S&P 500 annual percentage
change. And you can see here, very
obviously, and visually,
that there is a very, very close
relationship between the two. So also,
what's important to understand,
is the peaks and the peaks and the troughs
in the ISM. So you can see, for example,
that when the ISM
peaks at around the 60 level, this is when
S&P 500 or stock market annual returns. So
the performance of the stock
market peaks peaks as well. We can't
predict exactly the number that the S&P
500 will return. But what we can
say is that in a certain time period, it's
probably going to peak at that level.
Also, when you look at the
troughs in the ISM, you can see that the
returns of the S&P 500, the annual returns
trough as well.
So essentially, the ISM is leading by a
period of anything up to 12 months, the
annual percentage return of the S&P 500.
So again,
if we think of our dynamic predictor list,
the ISM manufacturing index, when it's
attempting to
predict or lead both economic growth and
the S&P 500, annual percentage change, the
ISM manufacturing
index is very useful to us as traders and
portfolio managers. So let's put all this
together as to how
we actually follow it and why it's useful
for traders and portfolio managers. So how
to follow this composite
ISM. So the ISM, as we've seen, it can be
a powerful leading indicator to the
business cycle. Following
it on a monthly basis and being on top of
the details really stacks the odds in our
favor. When you look at
the ISM, what you're actually looking at
is the business cycle itself. When the ISM
is above 50,
it is a strong indication that the US
economy is expanding and therefore S&P 500
returns will very
likely be positive. So from our analysis
as traders and portfolio managers, and
from our predictor list,
we can potentially predict the 1-1
situation. So what does that mean? If you
recall, that means the S&P 500
will rise and GDP will rise. So they rise
together. So above 50, that's the S&P 500
and GDP moving in the same
direction and rising together. And this is
what is happening most of the time. We are
in expansionary
conditions and the S&P 500 is rising. What
we can't do, and we've said this a number
of times so far
in the video series, is say with a very
high level of confidence, the exact level
that the S&P 500 is going to
rise. What we're trying to do here is
stack the odds in our favor by getting the
direction right,
okay? So that is the 1-1 situation which
occurs most of the time throughout
history.
In a minority of cases, we get the ISM
falling below 50. This is a strong
indication that the economy is
contracting and therefore S&P 500 returns
will very likely be negative if the
Federal Reserve
does not act, okay? So we can potentially
predict what the Fed is going to do,
or we can potentially predict the 0-0
situation. So the S&P 500 falling and GDP
following and falling as
well. So they both move in the same
direction and they both go negative. Now,
previously,
we mentioned peaks and drops in the ISM.
We can understand this a little bit better
now.
When the ISM is in decline from a peak,
it's a strong indication that the rate of
economic growth,
so the rate of expansion is starting to
slow down. When the ISM gets to
historically peaky levels,
what we can do here is potentially predict
the 0-1 situation. That the stock market
has got ahead of
itself and that there's going to be some
profit-taking, okay? So the 0-1 situation
is when the S&P 500 falls
and GDP growth is still positive, but it's
slowing down. So it's falling. The rate of
GDP growth is
falling, but it's still going to be
positive. Now, on the flip side, when the
ISM troughs, this is a strong
indication that the rate of economic
slowdown, so contraction, is actually
getting slower. It's slowing
down. It's turning, okay? So when the ISM
gets to historic trough levels, what are
we looking at?
We're looking at potentially predicting a
very strong 1-1 situation where the ISM
rebounds from the trough,
the S&P 500 rallies really hard, then the
S&P 500 rallies really hard and puts in a
positive performance,
and GDP growth is reported later as
positive. So this is why we follow the ISM
manufacturing index,
and the S&P 500, because it's a really
great leading indicator for GDP growth and
S&P 500 returns,
and we can use these data points to
understand what our future expectations
are for GDP growth and S&P 500
returns, so the stock market. And we can
have in our portfolios a predisposition of
a long, short, or neutral
bias in our portfolios. We can decide, for
example, during periods of expansion,
that we have a long bias, a net long bias
in our portfolio. We can, for example,
when the ISM looks
like it's peaking or in the process of
peaking, we can choose to rotate and get
neutral in our portfolios,
not necessarily going short, because
remember, there's still economic growth
predicted, it's just at a
slower rate. So we can switch our
portfolios up, we can potentially get
neutral in our portfolios.
When the ISM goes below 50, and we have a
time lag of a period of, say, 6 to 12
months,
we can start to decide to get short in our
portfolios. And at troughs, we can move to
a neutral to long net
bias in our portfolios. So this is a very,
very useful leading indicator for us. And
of course, we don't
just use the ISM manufacturing index to
have an understanding of an entire big
picture macroeconomic
view. We are looking at all leading
indicators and getting a better
perspective of what's going on.
So don't just use the ISM, use all of them
to understand what's really going on in
the market.
Now, of course, as well, we're not going
to be right all the time throughout our
careers. If we think about
our objectives here, it's to be
consistently profitable for a very long
period of time,
using our own money in retail trading
accounts. So if we're looking at our
entire career of, say,
the next 25, 30, 40 years, what percentage
of times are we actually going to predict
all of these
situations? Well, we're not going to be
hard on ourselves and say we have to be
right all the time.
Okay. But we're going to have a pretty
good idea of what's going on. So if we're
looking to
predict the 1-1 situation, this is most of
the time. And if you think about our
quadnomial analysis
and correlation analysis that we did in
previous videos, this analysis lines up
with actions that we
take from ISM with a time lag as well. So
using all of these leading indicators in
conjunction with each
other, we get a much clearer picture. So
the 1-1 situation happens most of the
time. If we can
potentially predict a number of 0-0
situations, that's great. But if we can
also predict some 0-1
situations, we don't have to get all of
them right. But if we can predict some 0-1
situations
throughout our career, what's going to
happen? Well, if we predict the 1-1, a
good number of 0-0s and a
good number of 0-1s, what's going to
happen? We're going to be right around 75%
of the time. So we're
going to be right somewhere between 60 and
80% of the time in predicting the US
economy, GDP growth and
predicting S&P 500 direction and potential
returns. So if we are using this leading
indicator, the ISM
manufacturing index, in our toolkit of all
of our leading indicators, in trying to
predict
GDP growth and S&P 500 direction and
returns, overall, if at the lower end in
our careers,
we're going to be right 60% of the time,
and at the higher end, 80% of the time, in
forming our
our predisposition, our macroeconomic
view, and our portfolio bias. Those odds
are pretty amazing.
Now, each month, when you're looking at
the ISM releases, what's going to happen
is you're going
to be going through a number of exercises
and updating your data and looking at all
of the
components of the aggregate diffusion
index. And if you recall, there were five
main components that we
are interested in. That was new orders,
production, employment, supplier
deliveries and inventories. And what
you're looking at on the screen here is a
chart of the data of new orders versus the
ISM manufacturing index,
the aggregate index from 1998 to present
day. And what you're going to find with
new orders is that
it's the most sensitive part of the
survey. It's the most sensitive component
of the ISM manufacturing data.
What you'll notice when you go through the
data in the past is that, typically,
because new orders is the most sensitive
part,
new orders will actually lead the ISM
manufacturing index itself. So, the new
orders index is a leading indicator of the
leading indicator.
New orders is something that you have to
be really on top of every month during the
ISM manufacturing data release.
Now, remember what the definition of new
orders actually is. It reflects the level
of new orders from customers of
manufacturing businesses.
So, it reflects the change month on month.
It's the most sensitive part of the ISM
manufacturing index.
Next up is the level of production. If you
recall, this measures the rate and
direction of change
change in the level of production at
manufacturing businesses who are included
in the survey.
So, by definition, when new orders come
in, of course, there will be a slight lag
to production to fulfill those new orders.
So, production is still a very sensitive
part of the ISM manufacturing index,
but it slightly lags new orders. Next up
is the employment component of the ISM.
Now,
this reports on a month-on-month basis the
rate of increase or decrease in the level
of employment at
manufacturing companies. Of course, this
is a much more of a slower-moving
indicator
versus other parts of the survey, like new
orders and production. These new hires,
month-on-month,
will basically follow the months of
expansion in new orders and production.
So, employment is more of a
slightly negative contributor or lagging
component within the five components
contributing to the overall
aggregate index. It's still good to stay
on top of it, obviously, but it's nowhere
near as sensitive as,
for example, new orders are, which
contributes very positively in terms of
its weighting relative
to the other equally weighted components.
Next up is supplier deliveries.
On the screen you can see supplier
deliveries versus the ISM manufacturing
index. What is this telling us?
Well, supplier deliveries reveals if
deliveries from suppliers are faster or
slower at manufacturing
businesses. If the manufacturing
businesses are experiencing faster
supplier deliveries, this basically
indicates that
suppliers are quicker to fulfill orders
that suppliers are quicker to fulfill
orders. Meaning that they're prepared to
invest more in the supply chain.
And that means they have an optimistic
outlook. And the reverse is true as well.
If the manufacturing businesses are
experiencing a slowdown, so slower
supplier deliveries, what's this
indicating?
Well, it indicates that suppliers are
slower to fulfill orders. And that means
that they're basically prepared to invest
less in the supply chain.
This means that the manufacturing
businesses themselves are getting more
pessimistic because it means that they're
not themselves prepared to invest further
in the supply chain.
And of course, the reverse is true if
order fulfillments are picking up and the
supply chain is reporting better
conditions month on month.
What does it mean? Well, it means that the
manufacturing company themselves and
suppliers are prepared to invest in the
supply chain.
What does it mean? Well, it means that the
supply chain is not as important as a
supply chain. And the supply chain is not
as important as new orders and production.
What does it mean? Well, it means that the
supply chain is not as important as new
orders and production.
It means that the supply chain is not as
important as new orders and production is
not as important as the supply chain is
not as important as new orders and the
supply chain is not as important as new
orders.
Of course, we still pay attention to it to
fill in the bigger picture of what's going
on in the manufacturing sector and the
economy overall, but we put less weighting
on its importance relative to other
components.
Next up is inventories. Remember,
inventories reflects the increases or
decreases in inventory levels at
manufacturing businesses, and it's a
pretty straightforward indicator to
understand.
If manufacturing businesses are increasing
inventories, it means they are getting
bullish because they believe that they're
going to get more orders in the future.
So order fulfilment will be going up. So
this is their expectation. So they're
increasing inventories.
The reverse. When inventories are being
drawn down by the company or by
manufacturing companies, what is
happening? Well, management are getting
bearish on the future of the company's
order fulfilment or pipeline.
So inventories is actually a sensitive
part of the overall ISM taken along with
new orders and production.
Inventories is one of the most important
components of the ISM Manufacturing Index.
So when you're doing your work every
month, just remember what these components
are all about and how much importance we
put on them as traders and portfolio
managers.
Obviously, they have an equal weighting of
20% each, but as traders and PMs, we place
more importance on some over others.
So just remember that new orders are the
most sensitive part of the report and the
most indicative of growth or contraction
overall.
It obviously stands to reason that
production for order fulfilment will be
positive or negative if new orders are
expanding or contracting.
Okay. Because production, obviously, for
order fulfilment follows new orders.
So production is important, it's
sensitive, but there's a slight time lag.
Employment is more of a slow moving
indicator versus new orders and
production.
When you have new hires month on month,
they are going to follow months of
expansion in new orders and production.
Supplier deliveries, we know what the
situation is there.
Faster supplier deliveries indicate that
suppliers are essentially quicker to
fulfil orders, meaning that they're
prepared to invest more in the supply
chain.
So they're becoming more optimistic.
Okay.
And the reverse is true.
When supplier deliveries are slowing, that
means suppliers are slower to fulfil
orders, meaning that they're prepared to
invest less in the supply chain and they
are becoming more pessimistic.
Something additional that supplier
deliveries does, it also indicates whether
there's potential supply chain problems
affecting particular industry conditions
within the manufacturing sector.
So although supplier deliveries is less
important and lagging factor or component
within the overall index, we still pay
attention to it.
So we're going to glean information where
we can glean information where we can on
whether there's any supply chain issues in
certain industries.
And if not, how good supply chains
actually are at any one moment in time in
a particular industry within the
manufacturing sector.
Lastly, inventories, this is a very easy
one to understand.
Management get bullish on their future
expectations of orders and order
fulfilment.
So they increase inventories and vice
versa.
They get bearish when they draw down
inventories because they're expecting less
orders and less order fulfilment.
So inventories, very sensitive part of the
overall ISM Manufacturing Index.
The most important three, as we've now
figured out, it's new orders, production
and inventories.
But really, it's new orders and
inventories because production follows.
Now, it's always useful to go through some
historic examples to have a look at how
you might use the ISM in conjunction with
tools that we've looked at up to this
point in the video series.
If you recall, when we covered real rates
and the yield curve in previous videos, we
looked at the second half of 2019.
And that was a time when the Fed cut
interest rates in July, September and
October 2019.
And that was in response to a slowdown in
the US economy.
Now, if you look on the screen, we've
taken a screenshot here from August 18th,
starting at August 18th, all the way up to
December 2020 of the ISM data and the
changes in the data.
And you can see at the first point we're
looking at here, August 18th, the ISM was
at 60.8.
Then one year later, the ISM went below 50
for the first time.
So in August 2019, it was 48.8.
Now, if we look at what happened to rates
in the US and the yield curve over that
same time period, what was actually
happening there?
Well, we can go to our downloads area.
We can download our yield curve data and
we can look at those two moments in time
and compare the yield curves.
So if we look firstly at the blue line, we
take this data and we look at what the
yield curve looked like on August the
12th, 2018.
And you can see very clearly when we look
at the blue line, it is a normal yield
curve, a positively sloped yield curve.
And when you marry this up with the ISM
data at a very high level, historically a
peak level of 60.8, this is something that
you would obviously expect.
Now, fast forward one year later, what's
happened to the yield curve?
Well, we now have an inversion.
So the short end of the curve is higher
than the long end of the curve.
And you can see that the official rate
itself.
So the Fed funds rate of 2.12 is higher
than the 10 year rate, which is 1.74.
And basically from one month money all the
way up to one year money, rates are higher
than the 10 year rate.
Also overall, what you notice is beyond
three month money is that all rates on the
curve are lower than one year previously.
Now, if we look at what was happening with
the ISM and the ISM report for August
2019.
And remember, the August 2019 report will
have been published in the first week of
September.
So when we look at that, what do we
actually see?
Well, this is what you'll see typically
every month when you check the ISM
manufacturing report.
You'll get a breakdown at the top level of
all of the components and the aggregate
index.
And you'll get language associated with
the actual monthly change.
So let's run through these.
We see from July to August, the aggregate
PMI goes from 51.2 to 49.1.
New orders goes below 50 as well.
Production goes below 50.
So does employment.
Supplier deliveries stays above 50 at
51.4.
And inventories go below 50 as well.
So our most important indicators, new
orders, inventories and production all go
below 50.
So the PMI goes below 50 at the aggregate
level.
And you can see on the right hand side of
this table, you can see the direction and
the rate of change and the trend in
months.
So the aggregate level PMI goes from
growing to contracting and contracting for
one month.
Inventories, you can see is contracting
and the trend in month.
The trend in months is three months.
So the question is, what actually happened
after this?
Well, if we look at the yield curve data
and we look at what happened in December
2019.
So if you recall, previously we looked at
August 2018 versus August 2019.
And we saw an inversion in the short end
of the curve for August 2019.
But what happened by December?
Well, a couple of things.
The short end flattened and went into
transition and started to form or started
to move towards a more normal upward
sloping positive yield curve.
So something obviously happened between
September and December.
What we also notice as well, of course,
all rates across the curve versus August
2018 are lower.
So we can see, for example, two year money
is a full 1% lower.
And we can see on 10 year money, roughly
the same, about 1% lower.
And what we can also see is the Fed funds
rate is 155.
So down from 2.12 in our previous chart,
August 2019.
So down around half a percent.
This is reflective of the Fed's rate cuts
in September and October.
So the rate cuts obviously had an effect
on the shape of the yield curve.
Now, something we mentioned a little bit
earlier in the video series, we looked at
the tens minus twos.
And we also previously looked at it in
August 2019.
Well, this is when the ISM went below 50.
It happened in the same month where there
was a slight inversion for a very, very
short space of time in the tens minus
twos.
It only lasted a few days.
So, yes, we mentioned in the video series
earlier that the tens minus twos didn't
really invert.
What we meant by that is it didn't really
invert by an amount that's meaningful for
a decent amount of time.
You can see on the chart here, towards the
end of August 2019, the tens minus twos
did invert by a tiny amount, five basis
points.
But then it went positive again.
So you can see in September following that
move, the tens minus twos goes positive.
The tens minus twos spread goes positive
by a decent amount in September and then
keeps on rallying September, October,
November and December.
Now, what was happening to the S&P 500
itself?
Well, if we look at a chart for 2019.
So let's start in Jan 2019 and go all the
way up to Jan 2020.
We can see that the stock market S&P 500
rallied into August 2019.
Then the stock market went down in August
2019 and was kind of flat from July to
September.
A small sell-off towards the end of
September, beginning of October.
But then the market just continued to
rally for the rest of the year.
And then when we look at January 2019 to
January 2020, if you recall, the market
was up in the year 2019 around 38%.
So we ask ourselves the obvious question
on this historical case study.
When the ISM was falling from around the
60 level towards the 50 level, why was the
stock market going up?
Well, it was because the economy was still
growing.
It was just growing at a slower rate.
Next question.
When the ISM went below 50 for the first
time, why did the market not sell off
aggressively?
Well, the market was looking at everything
that we look at.
And guess who else was looking at it?
The Federal Reserve.
So, yes, the Fed was looking at the ISM.
The Fed was looking at the yield curve.
And the Fed was looking at the stock
market as well.
And the private market was traders,
portfolio managers.
We were all looking at the same thing.
And then the market started to expect that
the Fed would cut rates.
So this is why the market didn't sell off
too aggressively.
There was just a small correction in the
market.
And then for the rest of 2019, the market
went up because the Fed actually did
something.
So let's run through this case study.
It's always a good exercise to do, not
just because you're in the learning
process of how to tie all of these things
together and how to use all of these tools
at any one moment in time.
But if we look at cases in stock market
history, it's just a good learning
experience to know what was going on at
the time.
We're building up your knowledge so you
can actually go and have a look at a lot
more past situations in the financial
markets and apply the same approach just
from a general learning perspective.
So let's put all this together.
What was actually going on at this moment
in time?
Well, we know in August 2018, when we look
at the data, the ISM peaked at 60.8 and it
continued on a steady decline till
December 2019.
The ISM went below 50 for the first time
in August 2019.
Remember, the report for August was
released in September.
That report is released on the first
business day of every month.
So that report was released on the first
business day of September.
Now, while the ISM was steadily declining
from its peak, so from September 2018, the
yield curve was in the process of
flattening.
And then the short end of the curve
inverted against the middle part of the
curve in spring 2019.
The yield curve at that time was
essentially flat, but it was threatening
to invert.
It was in transition.
And the tens minus twos only really
slightly inverted in August 2019.
Why?
Because the Fed saw the problem coming.
And they cut rates in July, then in
September and October in response to the
money market chaos and the ISM slowdown.
And the market itself was clearly
expecting lower rates from the Fed.
So the S&P 500 sold off between October
2018 and January 2019.
It went down approximately 17% while the
ISM was in decline from peak.
So we saw the decline in the ISM from its
peak.
Growth was slowing down and we got a 0-1
situation.
However, if you think back to the
definitions of bull and bear markets,
there was no official bear market.
A 20% move down from the high print of the
S&P 500.
After the Fed's rate cuts and in December
2019, the two-year and 10-year yields were
1% lower.
The yield curve had essentially steepened
and was flat at the front end and normal
at the back end.
What was happening?
It was in transition back to normal.
So basically, the Fed's actions stopped or
prevented a recession.
So a recession was averted.
So we didn't get two quarters of negative
GDP growth.
What did it take to have a recession?
Well, it took COVID-19 in 2020 to derail
everything.
That's when we had the economic shutdowns
or lockdowns and COVID-19 was essentially
an exogenous event responsible for the
recession in 2020.
Now, as I say, always a useful exercise to
go through these things.
But let's think about what you're going to
be doing on a monthly basis when you're
looking at ISM in isolation.
You're going to be essentially doing a
quantitative and qualitative assessment of
the ISM every month.
Now, in the beginning, the processes that
you implement will be obviously new to
you.
But don't worry, you'll get used to them.
You'll go from being slow at this to
getting quite quick and efficient over
time.
So let's have a look here at what you will
get when you get the data and put it into
your spreadsheets that we provided in the
downloads area.
So what we've got in front of us here is
what we've called the ISM heat map.
And we're looking at the period here from
April 2018 up till August 2019.
So we're including that period that year
we looked at August 18 to August 2019.
And if you recall, that's the period where
the ISM went from peak to going below 50.
What we've got on the screen with the ISM
heat map, if you cut it down the middle
and look to the left, you'll see the
aggregate PMI and you'll see the five
components of the aggregate PMI.
And then on the right hand side, you'll
see the areas in the survey that are not
included as part of the ISM aggregate PMI.
And what the heat map essentially does is
just give you a very quick visualization
via colors of growth and slowdown across
the data.
So when you look at, for example, a strong
green color, this is indicating strong
growth.
When you're looking at a yellow color,
this is indicating moderate growth.
When you're seeing an orange or red color,
this is inferring essentially contraction.
So when you're doing this on a monthly
basis, it's good to update this heat map
and just have a look at the bigger
picture.
You know, where have we come from in the
ISM?
Where are we now?
And where could we be going?
What is the direction we are going in?
And what does this all mean when we use it
in conjunction with other leading
indicators that we've covered up to this
point in the video series and that we're
going to cover in future parts of the
video series?
And also, what does it mean in perspective
of Fed policy?
These are the questions that we always
need to be asking ourselves and the heat
map itself just paints the bigger picture.
It paints the bigger picture of the
direction we are moving in and it
literally provides it to you visually.
Now, the ISM is not just useful to us as
traders and portfolio managers in
assessing the bigger picture and getting a
predisposition and therefore a portfolio
bias.
What it also does is it gives us potential
trade ideas.
So, we get in the ISM a lot of qualitative
statements and qualitative information
from the manufacturing companies
themselves.
And from that qualitative information and
also quantitative information, we can
infer potential trade ideas.
So, each of the 18 manufacturing
industries within the U.S. manufacturing
sector, they provide us with qualitative
information as part of the monthly ISM
survey.
And you can see on the screen here, the
example from August 2019.
They basically tell us every month, each
industry that is, whether they are growing
or contracting or there's been no change.
On the example here that you see on the
screen, you can see a snapshot of what was
reported in August 2019 from the 18
manufacturing industries.
So, we can see here, reading off the
screen, of the 18 manufacturing
industries, 9 reported growth in August in
the following order.
And then they list them in order as to how
strong they were reporting their growth.
And then there were 7 industries reporting
contraction in the following order.
So, least contracting to most contracting.
So, that leaves basically 2 where there
was no change.
So, we have 16, 9 plus 7 reporting growth,
9 and 7 contraction.
And then we have 2 that are not listed
here, that basically were reported flat.
Now, you'll see that we've highlighted 2
sectors here, chemical products and
transportation equipment.
Just for the purposes of an example of how
you might be thinking about things on a
monthly basis,
when you pull up both the quantitative and
qualitative information from ISM surveys.
And there is further qualitative
information available.
And this is why we've highlighted chemical
products and transportation.
So, you'll get some qualitative
information from the industries themselves
where they're actually making statements.
So, the purchasing managers of the
industries themselves.
So, particular companies within those
industries are making qualitative
statements about their business.
And you can see here from the August 2019
example, when we look at chemical
products.
There was a statement that was made by one
of the purchasing managers of a chemical
products company.
That was highlighted in the ISM report for
that month.
And that person was saying, while business
is strong, there is an undercurrent of
fear and alarm regarding the trade wars
and a potential recession.
And if you remember from the previous
slide, chemical products was the sector
that was growing, but growing at the
slowest pace.
Also, transportation equipment, there was
a qualitative statement made there by a
purchasing manager from one of the
manufacturing companies within that
sector.
And that person stated, slowest month,
referring to July, this year so far in
sales.
And if you recall back to the previous
slide, transportation equipment was
contracting at a fast pace when compared
to other sectors that were growing and
even contracting as well.
So, it's always good to have a look at
these past reports and actually go and see
how things panned out.
Remember, we're looking here at
quantitative and qualitative data from
companies within industries of the
manufacturing sector in the United States.
And we're looking at the actual earnings
reports of the companies themselves.
So, let's see how things panned out.
What we're looking at here is the stock,
Dow DuPont, which is the largest chemicals
conglomerate in the world, or at least
they were at the time period we're looking
at.
And we're looking at that relative to the
S&P 500, so the broader market.
And what we've got on the screen here is
basically both Dow DuPont and the S&P
indexed to 100 at the beginning of our
time period.
And what we've got on the screen is
starting in September 2018 and ending in
December 2019.
And what do we know about that period?
Well, that was the period that we've been
looking at throughout this video as an
example period of the ISM slowdown and the
Fed actions.
So, what we notice here is a few things.
So, first of all, we notice that over that
entire time period, the S&P 500 was up
around 11%.
So, the index goes from 100 in September
2018 to 111 by December 2019.
What do we notice about Dow DuPont?
So, Dow DuPont, the index starts at 100
and it goes down roughly 36%.
So, the stock goes down by 36% roughly to
December 2019.
And then when we compare this relative to
the S&P 500, there's obviously
underperformance of around 47%, which is a
very big underperformance.
But let's think about this in terms of the
storyline of how things panned out over
this time period and what was going on in
the background.
Well, we know in September when they
reported the August ISM, so September
2018, we know that was the peak in the
ISM.
And we see both the S&P 500 and Dow DuPont
go down together, but the S&P 500 was
outperforming Dow DuPont.
When we got into 2019, the S&P 500 started
to rally and then by springtime, so April,
May 2019, that's when the S&P was flat
versus September 2018.
But Dow DuPont didn't go higher, it
actually went lower.
So, by May time, you can see that Dow
DuPont is lower than where it was at the
beginning of 2019.
And then what happens?
Well, we get our August 2019 ISM report,
and we know what was happening around that
time.
We get our 2019 ISM report in September
2019, and guess what?
Dow DuPont doesn't rally.
But we know what was happening as well.
The Fed was actually cutting rates.
So, even though the Fed cut rates, Dow
DuPont didn't rally, but the S&P 500 did.
So, when we look back at quantitative and
qualitative data and statements in past
ISM reports, and
looking at this example, the August 2019
example, where the ISM went below 50 for
the first time, it's
interesting to see that when we look at
chemical products that were reporting
very, very slow
growth, and the slowest growth of all
sectors that were reporting growth, we
look at, for
example, the largest chemical conglomerate
at the time, and regardless of Fed action,
Dow DuPont
just didn't move.
It didn't go up.
It didn't really go down much.
It just kind of went sideways, but really
underperformed the broader market.
Now, if you recall, we also looked at
transportation equipment from our August
2019 report.
And here we have a company called
Greenbrier Companies.
Greenbrier essentially supplies
transportation equipment and services to
the railroad industry.
And we've again indexed this company
relative to the S&P 500.
And you can see a similar situation as we
saw in chemical products with Dow DuPont.
But actually, it's a little bit worse.
Of course, we get the usual situation that
we looked at with the S&P 500.
Previously, where over the period, it's up
around 11%.
So again, we're looking at the September
2018 period to December 2019.
But then you look at Greenbrier, which is
in the transportation equipment sector.
And these guys were down circa 45%.
So over this period, we have roughly a 56%
underperformance from Greenbrier relative
to the S&P 500.
And again, if we just look at some of the
details here, we know as the ISM peaked in
August 2018, which is our point of origin
at the beginning of September when the ISM
report caps out.
And then we look for the next, say six
months after that, Greenbrier
underperforms the S&P 500 as the ISM is
slowing down.
As we move into the spring of 2019, when
the ISM is hovering above 50, and then it
goes below 50 for the first time in August
2019,
but reported in September, Greenbrier for
the remainder of the year didn't go up.
It went sideways.
And remember, this was the period where in
the summer of 2019, the Fed was in the
market and responding to stresses in the
bond market and in the macroeconomic
leading indicators like the ISM.
And they were active cutting rates.
And what happened?
Greenbrier didn't respond to that and
essentially just went sideways while the
S&P 500 went up.
But overall, as the ISM slowed down from
peak over this entire period, Greenbrier
underperformed the S&P 500 by roughly 55,
56%.
So again, you can use the ISM not only for
figuring out which way the bigger picture
macro wind is blowing.
You can use it for specific industry
sectors and look at the data and listen to
what the companies are actually saying and
figure out what is going on and where
there might be areas for potential trade
ideas.
So you can get light bulb indications or
clues of where to look in the stock market
from ISM surveys.
On a monthly basis, you have to go through
a quantitative and qualitative process of
organizing the numbers and the qualitative
statements and looking for turning points,
looking for trends in the aggregate data
and also at a sector level.
Now, you don't just look at this in the
ISM and then decide to put a trade on.
Of course, you don't do that.
That's a rookie error.
And you've got to go through all of the
other processes that we're going to go
through in this video series to identify
potential stocks that will move from
indicated trends in the ISM.
You don't just stop here and then put a
trade on.
There's a lot more work to do.
Use the ISM as a place to get clues, clues
only as to what might be happening in some
sectors.
Then you've got to go through the rest of
the processes that are required to
generate what we actually define as a
genuine trade idea.
Do not look at a number in the ISM, then
look for any stock in the sector without
doing any further work.
Then think this is a trade idea and put a
position on.
You have to do a lot more work than that.
No shortcuts, please.
And also, do not rely on the ISM as the
only place you look for potential trade
ideas.
There's multiple ways to generate trade
ideas, not just with the ISM.
Now, when it comes to sectors, we don't
just get qualitative information.
We also get quantitative information
that's released by the ISM every month.
And if you go to the downloads area under
the video, download the ISM spreadsheet,
you'll see a file within the spreadsheet.
You'll see a tab called sectors.
And you'll see that for each area of the
report, that each sector provides the
change versus the last month with a
statement of growth, contraction or
neutral.
So here's an example from the second half
of 2020.
We've organized it so that in the
spreadsheet, it shows the last six
reports.
And you can update this information
yourself every month when the data comes
out.
It's very straightforward to do so.
And if you look at this table, we're
looking here at the ISM manufacturing
aggregate number that's reported by each
of the 18 manufacturing sectors.
So we've got the data here from July 2020
to December 2020.
And if you look at the sector data from
December 2020, you can see it's been
organized in descending order.
So we have the sector that's reporting the
biggest change in growth at the top.
So that is apparel, leather and allied
products.
And then at the bottom, we've got the
industry that's reporting the highest
amount of contraction month on month,
which is printing and related support
activities.
And so the rankings that we've applied
here in the spreadsheet for December 2020,
for example, the rankings refer to how
fast each sector is growing or contracting
relative to each other.
So for example, in December 2020, we've
sorted this month in descending order.
And there's 18 manufacturing industries,
16 of them reported growth and two
reported contraction.
And apparel, leather and allied products
is given a score of 16 because that is the
fastest growing sector reported that
month.
Furniture and related products is given
the rank of 15 wood products, 14.
And then we keep going all the way down.
We then get to sectors that are reported
as contracting.
So non-metallic mineral products and
printing and related support activities.
So of the 18 manufacturing industries,
apparel, leather and allied products is
reporting the strongest growth, printing
and related support activities, the
weakest growth, but not actually growth.
It's actually contraction.
What we can also see from this display
that you've got in the spreadsheet is a
couple of other things.
So you can also see the amount of months
in the last six months that a particular
sector has been growing or contracting or
where the turning points have occurred,
which is also very useful.
And also we're color coded.
So we're on a heat map here.
So visually you can see where contraction
is occurring, when it's occurred, and you
can see where growth is occurring and when
it's occurred.
But this is for the aggregate number.
This is for each sector's aggregate index.
We can also look at the sub components.
So we can look at, for example, new
orders.
And on a monthly basis, you would simply
go through these tables and firstly,
obviously organizing your data and
spreadsheets, but you would go through
these tables and start to look for clues
of turning points and trends for potential
trade ideas.
Something that you might notice in new
orders may counter what you're seeing in
the aggregate number.
And remember, new orders tends to lead the
aggregate number.
New orders are the most sensitive.
So for example, in this table, something
that may jump off the page to you is
textile mills.
Textile mills is reporting contraction
coming from the previous month.
So reporting contraction in December 2020
coming from a previous month of growth in
new orders in November 2020.
And if we go to the previous slide, we can
see that textile mills as a sector was
reporting some slow growth and had a
ranking of four out of our 18
manufacturing sectors.
So this is something that might, you know,
jump off the page to you.
You would do a lot more work, obviously,
and you would start looking for potential
trends and potential turning points in
these sectors from growth to contraction
or contraction to growth.
We also have production in there.
We also have employment, deliveries,
deliveries, and inventories.
And inventories, again, inventories is an
important one.
You would probably look at inventories for
turning points going from contraction to
growth and growth to contraction and look
for trends.
And something, you know, that may jump off
the page here is, for example, furniture
and related products.
So if you look at the last two months for
furniture and related products, what's
been happening?
Well, inventories are being drawn down.
And if we go back to our first page, where
we look at the aggregate number, we can
see that furniture and related products on
an aggregate level is reporting the second
highest amount of growth in December.
So we would do a bit more work on that.
We would figure out where the positive
contribution is coming from.
But this is not a good sign that
inventories are being drawn down in
furniture and related products.
And that's a good sign.
Because purchasing managers are literally
telling us, in the information provided
via the ISM reports, that on a relative
basis, furniture and related products
inventories are being drawn down very
quickly compared to other sectors.
Now, that might be a seasonal issue.
We obviously have to do much more work on
this and do work on the sector itself and
particular stocks in the sector to get
anywhere near a potential trade idea.
But the ISM is a good starting point for
providing potentially those light bulb
moments for providing clues.
So that's up for you to decide.
And that's work that you need to do when
you're generating potential trade ideas.
Also on a monthly basis, when you're
collecting the data and information from
the ISM report, you'll see here a tab in
the spreadsheet download called industry
comments.
And yes, you will fill in this every month
and you will type out the industry
comments in your spreadsheet.
So you've got them easily referenced in
your spreadsheet and you can go back and
look at them.
It's a good exercise to do.
Why?
Because if you force yourself to type
these out every month, it means the
information is more likely to be
understood and internalized.
And you'll be more likely to use that
information to generate potential trade
ideas.
And this is what we mean if you think back
to ITPM principles of relying on yourself.
You've got to do further work on the ISM
manufacturing report on business.
Self-educate a bit more on the various
areas of the ISM manufacturing report.
Continue to do more work on understanding
each of the components of the diffusion
index.
So new orders, production, employment,
supplier deliveries and inventories, and
also do more work on what's not included
in the diffusion index.
So become a student of the ISM.
What we've done here is covered all of the
most important stuff and provided you with
a gateway education on what the ISM
manufacturing report on business is all
about.
It's a very, very valuable resource and
valuable information can be gleaned from
this data on a monthly basis if you have a
self-starter mentality and you choose to
do the work.
Okay.
Indulging in a spoon feeding activity and
copy trading of other people.
So getting your ideas from other people is
never going to make you a consistently
profitable trader.
You have to generate your own trade ideas.
You have to do your own trade ideas.
You have to do your own work, generate
your own trade ideas and make your own
returns.
So use the resources in the downloads
area, continue learning and implement
monthly processes to be on top of the
data.
Okay.
Now let's summarize what the ISM
manufacturing report on business is all
about.
It's one of the most important leading
indicators in the world for pro traders
and portfolio managers.
U.S. GDP, it drives global GDP and stock
market returns in the U.S. and the rest of
the world.
Professional traders are using the ISM as
a guide and in conjunction with money
market indicators and other leading
indicators as a guide to portfolio
direction.
So whether we're going to be net long or
short or neutral in our portfolio.
We're going to get into this much later in
the video series about portfolio
direction.
We can also look for clues in the ISM at a
sectoral level.
So as to how companies will potentially
report their earnings in the future.
So in upcoming quarters.
So the ISM can therefore also potentially
help us to generate trade ideas in single
stocks within particular sectors.
So for a long short portfolio.
Also, as we've seen, when we looked at
examples in the past, the ISM also tells
us what we should expect from the Fed in
terms of likely policy response.
Remember, the Fed is looking at the ISM as
well.
So overall, the ISM manufacturing reports
on business is just a great leading
indicator that's going to enable us to be
right somewhere between 60% and 80% in our
estimation of the U.S. economy and
directional bias in our portfolio.
So our bias of long short or neutral.
When we use the ISM in conjunction with
money market leading indicators that we've
covered in videos four to six and with
other macroeconomic indicators that we're
going to be covering in the rest of the
PTM video series.
We're going to have a very good
understanding of the U.S. economy, money
flows and potential Fed policy.
So you have to be on top of the ISM as
well as all of the other leading
indicators every month.
Every month, OK, at any one point in time,
you need to be on top of these things.
So when we look at our dynamic predictor
list, if you recall, we have government
and corporate bond market liquidity and
money flows, stock market liquidity and
volatility and stock market direction and
possible returns.
We're going to be on top of these things.
And then we have in our dynamic predictor
list, everything that's lagging.
Inflation, stock market, corporate
earnings outlook, and GDP, economic
growth.
And what we're trying to do is predict all
of these things and use stocks as our
instrument
to make money out of our predictions and
what's going to happen in the future.
But we are using leading indicators to
make our predictions.
And if you recall, we have real interest
rates and the yield curve.
That's in the government bond market.
We have investment grade and high yield or
junk spreads over the 10-year.
That's in the corporate bond market.
We have M2 money supply growth as an
accessory.
And we also have the VIX from the IPLT.
But now we're adding in surveys.
And the ISM Manufacturing Report on
Business is one of the surveys that we're
going to be looking at.
We're going to be looking at more surveys
in future videos.
And we're going to move on to the next
video now.
And we're actually going to be looking at
the services sector.
So the ISM non-manufacturing reports on
business.
See you in the next video.
in the next video.